et le cad alexeï navalni a été source de
tensions notamment entre washington et
moscou les autorités américaines ont
rapidement condamné l'empoisonnement
présumé de l'opposant russe si le
dossier a été abordé de manière
différente par donald trump et joe biden
il a conduit à de nouvelles sanctions
américaines et précision avec thomas
boni
dès les premiers jours qui ont suivi
l'empoisonnement présumé d' alexeï
navalni médias et hommes politiques
américains se sont empressés de tirer
des conclusions hâtives attribuant la
responsabilité de cet acte au
gouvernement russe pour ce qu'ils ont
qualifié de tentative d'assassinât
en dépit de toute enquête c'est bille en
tête que certaines voix américaines ont
poussé pour une réaction forte de la
part de la maison blanche et pourtant au
mois de septembre 2020 donald trump se
montre lui particulièrement prudent
je ne sais pas exactement ce qu'il s'est
passé je pense que c'est triste c'est
tragique c'est terrible cela ne devrait
pas arriver on n'a pas encore de preuves
mais je suivrai ça il est intéressant de
voir que tout le monde mentionne la
russie et cela ne me dérange pas que
tout le monde mentionne la russie mais
je pense que probablement la chine à ce
stade est une nation dont on devrait
davantage parler bien plus que la russie
car les choses que fait la chine sont
bien pires
et puis quelques jours plus tard mike
pompéo qui était alors chef de la
diplomatie américaine va a lui aussi
adhéré à la thèse d'une tentative
d'assassinât fomentée par des hauts
responsables russes et puis au fil des
semaines des élus républicains comme
démocrates vont presser washington de
prendre des mesures notamment des
sanctions contre le projet de gazoduc
north stream 2 les autorités russes
accusent alors les états unis de se
servir de la sphère navalni comme d'un
prétexte pour se poser à ce projet de
gazoduc est déjà décriée depuis
longtemps de ce côté de l'atlantique
moscou qui va également accusé
l'ambassade américaine en russie de
soutenir les manifestations de soutien à
navalni notamment en publiant sur son
site les itinéraires des cortèges qui
ont pourtant été interdite par les
autorités russes et puis avec l'arrivée
de joe biden à la maison blanche au
début de l'année 2000 21 les sanctions
entre en application mise en place au
mois de mars 2021 joe biden qui a fait
du changement de ton envers la russie
marque de rupture avec son prédécesseur
se montre volontairement menace en
utilisant là encore le dossier navalni
comme un chiffon rouge novembre his
death la mort de navalni serait une
nouvelle indication que la russie n'a
pas été l'intention de respecter les
droits humains fondamentaux
ce serait une tragédie cela ne fera que
nuire à ses relations avec le reste du
monde à mon avis et avec mon
resto
hellmuth mais depuis les deux présidents
se sont rencontrés ils ont pu aborder ce
sujet même si les conférences de presse
qui ont suivi leurs rencontres nous ont
montré que les positions étaient encore
assez éloignée d'ailleurs preuve en est
puisque quelques jours après le fameux
sommet de genève le conseiller national
de la sécurité américaines a expliqué à
la télévision que de nouvelles sanctions
étaient en préparation contre moscou la
sphère navalni est en fait les
illustrations des tensions entre les
deux puissances si celles ci ont réussi
à s'entendre sur un certain nombre de
sujets ces dernières semaines le cas de
cet opposant russe reste un sujet deux
confrontations depuis maintenant un an